sometimes I will watch movie and it'll
be abundantly clear that it wasn't made
for critics it was made for people like
us
entourage the movie so the entourage
movie springboards off the foundation
that the entourage series on HBO bill
this movie does the greatest thing it
could have ever done that I was thinking
they were going to do but I didn't know
for sure it takes the entire final
season of Entourage and just sweeps it
away it still acknowledges that the
events of that season did happen but
ultimately if you never watch that
season it's not going to affect this at
all in fact you don't need to have
watched the series in order to enjoy the
movie but it does help but the point is
everything that happened in that last
season doesn't matter here Turtles a
millionaire's those basically
cherry-picks like the things that you
liked stick the things that you didn't
they're gone so in the entourage movie
Ari Gold's a studio exec Ari wants Vince
to do his first feature film with studio
execs and Vince's like well yeah if I
direct so now this is Vincent chases
directorial debut and after that it's
all about getting the money to do it the
stress the living it up in Hollywood
it sounds really convoluted but it's
really everything that the entourage
show had to offer in an hour and a half
to two hours and I'm used to an
entourage storyline being ten hours long
as those like whom they cram in two
hours and make it work yes absolutely
they do that in fact this is the finale
that the show deserve it gives you
everything absolutely everything it's
like a really good port of a home
console game on a handheld like gameboy
advance you're like how can they
possibly oh god they did it's perfect
that's what this is nothing is light
about it the shenanigans among the crew
in this movie they exist and are at full
force yes if you've ever thought to
yourself the entourage looks like Sex in
the City for dudes it's because it is
Jeremy Piven as Ari Gold I'm not gonna
lie I was so scared going into this
movie I was like maybe Ari Gold's not
going to have enough screen time it's
only two hours long how on earth they
gonna have the studio exec guy having
the screen time that the agent who was
first hands with the client had but they
completely do it a hundred percent I'm
not saying he's not gonna piss some
people off they're gonna be some reviews
out they're gonna be like sir
narcissistic I can't even find Danny but
we do because he's funny I even like the
newcomers in his movie Billy Bob
Thornton and Haley Joel Osment Haley
Joel Osment plays Billy Bob Thornton's
son under these two
Hicks from Texas really don't know how
the movie industry works in the light
record man what better but they're
financing the movie and so they just
have to deal with hut strats Johnny
Drama quickly became one of my favorite
characters in the entourage show so I
was glad that he's kind of in the
forefront of this movie he's not the
main character I don't know this movie
has a main character it has an entourage
but his character and his quest get a
lot of screen time I was just impressed
with the dialogue synergy and chemistry
between the characters in this movie you
feel like you were just watching a bunch
of friends it's that natural for them
and if it takes you along for the ride
that's a really invaluable thing for a
movie to do for you the viewer they
don't all do that a lot of them tried
not a lot succeed the cameos got a bit
exhausting at times though I mean the
thing about Entourage is in Hollywood so
most of times you see an actor and they
play themselves and I stop and say a
couple words but my god anytime
someone's hurrying somewhere there's
going to be a big-time actor or famous
person or an important person in
Hollywood is some sort of like hey Ari
you still owe me for that thing like oh
yeah Jessica Alba get to it it happens
so much in this movie I'm like I get it
man cameos everywhere let's let's go on
if they got a million dollars from every
big actor or celebrity or important
person that cameoed in this movie the
movie you'd be completely financed so
I'm pretty sure that's how they did it
the rabbit trail shenanigans do get a
little convoluted at times but
ultimately it has to do with the
characters love lives and you're like
should I care about that like the Sloan
Romance thing weren't we all just over
that [ __ ] years ago why is it even in
this movie because why don't you think
it's going to happen when you've watched
the show you've seen it enough you're
over it yet you have to choke it down
again or - you haven't seen the show so
it's going to be this out-of-left-field
romance where you're like am I supposed
to care about that I don't just feels
like a waste of time I want to know why
it was even in here there are a lot of
characters from the entourage show that
didn't make it in the movie so why did a
manual shrinkies character have to make
you guys in the end entourage was
everything I wanted the entourage movie
to be they had the characters the fun
the style the charisma this is not gonna
be everyone's cup of tea I need you to
know that they're gonna be people out
there who are like I didn't get it at
all
I love polarizing movies like this movie
four people will either love or hate I
just I like that I don't know why it's
just an interesting cultural thing in
the end I am certainly going to buy
Entourage on blu-ray
people find Danny alright guys so
entourage the movie have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more